Here's why 2024 is so important.
2024 is set to be a pivotal year for elections,
and thus the geopolitical landscape of the world,
with over 60 national elections taking place,
seven of which are in the world's most populous
countries. First and foremost
is the US presidential election,
where incumbent President
Biden will likely face former President Trump
in an electoral battle for the White House,
which will certainly have implications for the ongoing
conflicts in Ukraine and Gaza,
to name a few,
as well as American relations with China.
In Latin America,
Mexico's election is significant,
having implications for its
relations with its northern neighbor, the US,
especially in terms of trade,
immigration,
and security cooperation.
India's elections will be closely watched
as the country
continues to rise as a major global power.
The outcome will not only shape its domestic policies,
but also determine its role in regional geopolitics,
particularly concerning China.
Russia is also set to hold elections,
which will almost certainly see the return of Vladimir
Putin as president and the continuing
of the state's current geopolitical trajectory.
Equally pivotal are elections in Indonesia,
the UK, Germany,
the European Union,
Brazil, Turkey,
Iran, and Pakistan,
as each of these countries and the EU
hold significant positions
in the global geopolitical puzzle.
Sign up for our geopolitics weekly newsletter.
Link in bio.